Her low freak bitches outfit.
I mean I've worn costumes like that.
Just sound like sketches and shit.
Okay,
what is going on here in this picture?
This is so strange.
They're courting each other.
They're holding hands and steering and juices eyes like,
you know what this says?
It's like you saw cartoons and you're a little kid and they just fucked your
brain.
I'd be like,
well this is what I'm looking forward to when I get out of this house.
And he got out of the house.
You hear car accidents,
gunshots,
rape.
But do they fuck each other while they're both wearing a costume or do they fuck
people that aren't wearing a costume?
Apparently.
And this is I f I'm sorry if you are a member of the furry community and I
misrepresent you,
but some of them have hatches where their asshole is sort of like those old
school pajamas and those a wild west cartoons and we're the wild west pajamas
where they had like a like pop.
I always had those Dukie flap and you got two buttons that cover your Shitter,
like the shit trap and you open up the trap door and drop a bomb in there and
then button that fucker back up.
They didn't have,
they probably had drawstrings.
He probably didn't even have like rubber waistbands back then.
Right.
Like how different they like those big buttons on either side.
How do they tighten down your uh,
underwear?
Back then it was buttons.
That makes sense.
They probably had buttons in the front,
buttons in the Shitter.
He did buttons on everything back then.
So these kids,
they thought that was the future.
And then they went out there and they got punched in the face the moment they
left their house.
And then probably somebody did terrible things to them and they went to school
and they got picked on.
And then here they are just wishing they were a squirrel.
Oh this is the,
the squirrel just look in the courtroom.
And it was my favorite toy when I was young.
Then watch this girl cartoon and be like,
Oh,
I want to be in a squirrel.
We don't want to go to school and want to do the same.
We just want to be a squirrel.
Well the hotel where we were at,
they got to request it was,
they're filled up with furries except me and a few of the other UFC staff.
I'm not,
I'm not lying.
It's a fill.
Dazing and they got a request and the request was the ferries asked if they
could put a litter box in the lobby.
No Way.
Yes.
They wanted to pay for her litter box.
We brought into the lobby.
They like this whole convention is all us,
so can we do that?
And like I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
They took my idea for cats.
They tried to get a litter box and put it in the front lobby of like the Westin
in Pittsburgh to make smelly in apparently.
I mean it could have all just been just they get to be like,
come on man.
Well they definitely were asking for food to be delivered in bowls on the
ground.
Whatever they ordered.
They wanted to put a bowl like a dog food bowl and eat it on the ground.
Right.
It was several different rooms that were requesting this that I can see though,
if you're going to go that distance,
if you're not taking a shit in the fucking lobby.
Right.
You want to know?
You don't know until you ask.
Think it's all us.
It's all us here.
It's just all us.
We're amongst friends.
We'll pay,
we'll pay him.
Let me just ask.
Let's just ask like they're so crazy.
They just probably asked.
Yeah,
I mean I get,
it's like have,
they'll just have a litter box in your room and the lobby.
Yeah.
Come on man.
I bet a lot of them had them in their
going up that fucking flight of stairs with a duffle bag fill.
What litter
is there?
It's part of the sport.
And when I came into bodybuilding,
it's not like I invented steroids with already there,
you know,
my first semester and in Paris in 1965,
Larry Scott and was the Mr of MP or 90 65.
And he said he was using steroids and that was 1965.
So when did this start being used?
I don't know,
but for sure in the early sixties,
1965 they had steroids.
When did they invent steroids?
Uh,
I believe,
well you had testosterone.
I mean testosterone was used in the Second World War.
The Germans were using that with the SS soldiers.
Um,
so injectable testosterone was available then steroids,
which there were more refined version of testosterone.
Um,
I think late fifties.
How has it more refined in what way?
So he got testosterone is a male hormone,
so it's basically 50% androgenic that's male,
like characteristics,
50% anabolic repair bill.
So they want it to take this and they want to this pot,
the anabolic and minimize the androgenic cause that's what gives you side
effects,
prostate growth and all that stuff.
So they try,
they refined it so that those effects are minimized and more of the anabolic
effect.
That was the idea.
And there's a guy called John Siegler I think.
And because they found out the eastern bloc,
they had their own,
had their own stuff called [inaudible].
So,
uh,
Siegler invented Dinah Ball,
and I don't know,
don't quote me if I could be wrong,
but I think it was about 58 or something like that.
He developed that the u s weightlifting team,
1958,
I think it was 58.
But before that you had testosterone.
So they were known as what,
uh,
when people started using it,
but for sure from the early sixties,
it's been a part of bodybuilding and then other sports.
And they used to be a disclaimer inside the steroid thing saying anabolic
steroids do not increase athletic performance.
That's hilarious.
All right.
So they stated this and they also told guys,
if you take this,
you fucking balls are going to drop off,
you're going to fucking die,
you're going to get liver cancer.
So guys started using them and seeing that that's all bullshit.
Right.
So then they don't want to listen to anything that he's medical guys,
I've got to say,
cause you aligned to us then.
Right?
So you're going to be aligned to us all the time.
Not necessarily.
So yeah,
because you do have the chances of side effects,
but it,
you could say it's been greatly exaggerated and certain that's the problem was a
propaganda and deception,
right.
People,
the fucking truth man.
And let them deal with it.
And uh,
that's what I do.
Um,
because I saw all this stuff on the Internet about what I'm supposedly doing and
I thought young guys are going to read this and maybe they're going to do it.
So I did an article in a magazine,
muscular development,
and I said,
here,
this is what I did.
This is what I did in Austin.
This is what I did for a contest and these are my opinions.
And you know,
my honest opinion is like,
I don't think it's worth it unless you,
you know,
you're competing and so on.
But ultimately it's up to you.
Let me give you the information.
What you do with is up to you.
And I don't know for 70% of the people like this is bullshit.
He didn't really,
he must have talked much more than this because I'm taking this,
actually I'm taking more than this
and I don't look like him.
Well tough shit man.
You know
I always tell kids who want to be in this business to please wait like even with
my kids is it just wait,
wait til you're like wait to get an understanding.
Like I was able to be grown and and have some grown shit happened to me and just
regular life shit happens.
So then when this happened,
I still have a point of reference to get back to because you know like I know
you've interviewed everybody.
This business affects you in such a way where you'll see one person one day,
I won't say the comedian's name,
but I remember a comedian back in the day did like half of an HBO or whatever.
And then the next week I saw him,
he had 12 body guards and they were pushing me back.
What the fuck man?
Yo Man,
Yo know now.
Right now it just got crazy.
It got crazy,
crazy good,
crazy cause.
And I've seen,
I remember,
I won't say the names would have been a couple of guys,
I never get this one dude hit.
And I went up to try to say something to him and,
and for some reason he had a white suit on.
We were in a club.
I,
why the fuck does he have this white suit on and these big shapes.
And I went to talk to him and he said,
not right now man,
I'm rich.
Hmm.
He said that
they got rich,
let me be rich and famous right now.
I don't want to hear your pitch.
And some I said,
man,
you think you can get away.
And I was like,
and as he said it,
I had to sort of like,
okay,
I had to get up.
But that's,
you know,
that's what happens when you gotta be careful.
That tide goes in and it goes out and people come up and they remember,
they remember and we remember when you fucked with them.
And we've seen and we've seen him,
we've seen him.
But,
but being a comedian,
we get,
we get a chance to sit in a different seat because we sort of are our jobs or
our observational,
you know,
so,
and we still all have our own demons,
but it's,
it's just different when you also get humbled a lot as a comedian.
Yeah.
You gotta get those jokes.
You're performing in front of a live audience.
It's all live.
It's got to work and it doesn't work.
Shit.
You gotta go back to the drawing board and it's got to assess,
actors don't get a lot of that.
And that's one of the reasons why the kind of shaky,
more shaky.
Yeah.
Right.
Don't get a lot of like testing it live in front of people,
that humility that comes with that you don't.
And,
and it's,
and it's tough.
I was talking to her act,
another actor,
and it's tough cause see,
I'm a comic who became an actor,
so I'm cheating.
You know what I'm saying?
I can go do this and I can go,
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be in Saint Louis tomorrow.
You know,
some jokes.
So I can,
you know,
I gotta get,
I can get my thing off.
But just actors,
it's tough when you're thinking about a way to bounce three careers you can sing
too.
I mean,
you could do anything.
You're a weird guy.
That way.
You've got a lot of weird talent yourself.
And it's talking about Justin Bieber and yeah,
Chris Brown,
you've got some weird ability to shift to.
It's not only,
but I've been fortunate in the fact that now things have opened up.
Like,
you know,
back in the day,
like you could only do one thing.
One thing I would never forget Keenan Ivory Wayans told me,
say,
Yo,
what's with the singing shit?
you want a month?
Like I can't see you tried to sing and see.
Well,
I would,
I would try to sing a girl.
I'd be like,
can you see then know of is real and bands,
oh Jamie,
stop youtube finally in the faith base is too funny.
I see one the thing and to me youth spinal does stop.
So I was like,
fuck,
maybe I never seen it.
Okay.